[Aplausos]
[Música]
antes de empezar este vídeo tengo que
haceros dos advertencias la primera es
que vamos a hacer spoilers de la serie
narcos aunque tratándose de una serie
que relata un acontecimiento histórico
no creo que sea ningún problema pero
bueno yo por si acaso ahí os lo dejo la
segunda es que vamos a hablar del
narcotráfico que se trata de un tema muy
opaco y donde casi toda la información
que se puede encontrar es incompleta y
en cualquier momento pueden aparecer
nuevos hallazgos policiales que
invaliden los conocimientos previos
dicho esto vamos a empezar
colombia es conocido como el país de los
mil ritmos el lugar donde se cultiva el
mejor café del mundo y donde han nacido
todos esos artistas colombianos que le
gustan a tu novia sin embargo lo que ha
hecho que colombia sea tristemente
famosa es este señor de aquí fue pablo
emilio escobar gaviria haciendo negocios
equipo es fresco el rey de la cocaína el
hombre que creó un negocio tan peligroso
como rentable a finales de los años 80
pablo escobar o pablo como le conocen
sus vecinos de medellín controlaba nada
menos que el 90 por ciento de la cocaína
que se vendía en todo el planeta
de repente medellín que es una ciudad de
colombia con unos 2 millones de
habitantes se convirtió en el hollywood
de la cocaína y como todos ya sabéis el
1 de diciembre de 1993 pablo escobar
murió en un tiroteo a manos de la
policía colombiana
[Música]
ahora la pregunta es qué pasó después
quién recuperó el testigo que había
dejado pablo escobar y lo que es más
importante todavía existe tráfico de
cocaína en colombia hoy vamos a
responder a esa pregunta y lo vamos a
hacer de la mano de un hombre que vive
en las mismas calles que en su día
tránsito el mismísimo pablo escobar
[Música]
porque si amigos de visual político hoy
tenemos al músico más talentoso de todo
medellín al sex simbol paisa al hombre
que compuso la música que está sonando
ahora mismo efectivamente estamos
hablando de rick vallejo buena fonseca y
no abrazo todos los suscriptores de
visual político tal y como dices todos
los colores todo lo leyenda aquí en la
ciudad de medellín
incluso se va a construir un propio han
llamado barrio pablo escobar ahora
oficialmente conocido como barrio de
shinjuku los ofrecen todos sus crímenes
y afectados terroristas lastimosamente
todavía puedes ver pelados o sea
adolescentes si tomamos acá queriendo
ser como ven que aspiran llegar a ser
como él
[Música]
pero antes de hablar de la era post
pablo escobar tenemos que hablar de la
cocaína si normalmente decimos que el
petróleo es el oro negro la cocaína bien
podría llamarse el oro blanco se trata
de la droga ilegal más consumida en el
mundo después de la marihuana pero hay
una diferencia la marihuana se puede
cultivar en cualquier lugar del planeta
incluso en el norte de europa la policía
encuentra muchas veces plantaciones
domésticas de cannabis prácticamente
cualquier persona con muy poquitos
medios puede reproducir las condiciones
climáticas necesarias para cultivar
marihuana sin embargo la hoja de coca
necesita un hábitat muy específico sin
duda
[Aplausos]
ok
tan específico que solamente se puede
cultivar en unos poquitos países
principalmente colombia perú y bolivia
en otras palabras hay espacio para muy
poquitos proveedores pero sin embargo la
demanda es enorme nunca cesa y es a
nivel mundial y por eso el negocio de la
cocaína es uno de los más rentables que
existen y precisamente por eso cuando
pablo escobar dejó un espacio vacío en
esta industria no faltaban candidatos
para llenarlo
guerra de mafias como sabéis pablo
escobar era el líder del cartel de
medellín pero ya incluso antes de su
muerte
medellín no era la única capital de la
coca también había un grupo de
narcotraficantes muy importantes en esta
otra ciudad que vemos aquí que se llama
cali y que además tiene más o menos la
misma población que medellín mientras
pablo dejó un rastro de cuerpos y caos a
su paso
cali hizo desaparecer los problemas con
un ejército de abogados y una montaña de
informes judiciales el cartel de
medellín era como miami piscinas chicas
en bikini horteras como un cadillac
bicolor
el cartel de cali era como nueva york'
elegante fino sutil podían animar la
fiesta durante horas con cocaína y aún
así asegurarse de que todo el mundo se
presentase al trabajo en wall street' a
la mañana siguiente al principio
medellín y cali trabajaron codo con codo
pero en colombia cuando hay dinero de
por medio e inevitablemente la sangre
corre tras la muerte de pablo escobar el
cartel de cali esperaba hacerse con todo
el negocio de pablo escobar sin embargo
en su propia ciudad natal en medellín
también había un montón de bandas
pequeñitas intentando hacer la misma
operación uno de estos pequeños líderes
del narcotráfico que por cierto también
aparece en la serie era diego fernando
murillo alias 'don berna'
bueno ya sabéis don berna ayudo tanto a
la policía colombiana como a la
estadounidense a acabar con pablo
escobar incluso llegó a aliarse con el
cartel de cali y con un grupo de
paramilitares de extrema derecha
llamados las autodefensas ünidas de
colombia con el rey de la cocaína muerto
el cartel de cali se fue por su lado y
don berna se quedó en medellín empezando
su pequeño negocio de exportación de
cocaína además tenía al grupo de
paramilitares que le podía ayudar a
protegerlo dicho de otra forma las
autodefensas ünidas de colombia le
proporcionaban la seguridad y don berna
ponía su extenso conocimiento del
mercado y esa metodología que había
aprendido tras años de trabajar con los
socios de pablo escobar así es como
nació la llamada oficina de envigado
[Música]
luchaban por conseguir él
esta calle que puedes ver acá al google
maps hace muchos años trazado
de las zonas entre bandas enemigas
entonces por ejemplo si tuviera va a
destacar y aquí mira del final
de este lado era una menta
lo más probable es criticar
[Música]
tanto el cartel de cali utilizaba unos
métodos mucho más sutiles como se ve en
la serie tanto gilberto rodríguez como
su socio el pacho herrera eran gente de
clase alta con contactos entre la clase
política los abogados y los jueces es
más el propio gilberto llegó a donar más
de 6 millones de dólares para financiar
la campaña electoral de ernesto samper
que después llegaría a convertirse nada
menos que en presidente de colombia sin
embargo poco importó la corrupción y el
tráfico de influencias
tarde o temprano pasó lo inevitable y a
sonia el gobierno inició las gestiones
para la extradición de miguel rodríguez
orejuela en la cárcel de palogordo en
girón santander donde está recluido el
jefe del cartel de cali no podemos decir
lo mismo de don berna es más de todos
los personajes que han aparecido en
estas dos primeras temporadas de narcos
don berna es el que más tiempo ha sido
capaz de escapar de la justicia pero
esperad un momento porque ahora es
cuando vamos a hablar de esos personajes
que no salen en la serie y preparaos
porque hay para rato
queréis que os decía que don berna se
había aliado con un grupo de
paramilitares de extrema derecha para
que protegieran sus operaciones pues en
este caso la ideología política
importante
[Música]
y las autodefensas unidas de colombia
nacieron con el propósito de combatir
las guerrillas marxistas leninistas que
estaban en la selva y si en arcones nos
hablan del m-19 pero sin duda alguna la
más importante de todas ellas es esta
y fuerzas armadas revolucionarias de
colombia decir que las farc son un grupo
terrorista es quedarse corto en algunos
momentos llegaron a ser todo un estado
paralelo al gobierno de colombia lo más
parecido a lo que las podemos comparar
es a lo que hoy en día es el daes o el
estado islámico buena parte de lo que es
la selva colombiana estaba bajo el
control de esta guerrilla comunista de
las farc controlaban a los médicos los
hospitales los profesores de las
escuelas e incluso llegaban a cobrar sus
propios impuestos se estima que el grupo
tiene 120 mil miembros distribuidos en
24 de las 32 provincias colombianas y
como os podéis imaginar a las farc
tampoco les hacía mucha gracia a los
narcotraficantes sí vale es verdad que
tanto los narcos como los terroristas
tenían a varios enemigos en común pero
tendréis que reconocerme que la idea de
hacerse millonario vendiendo un producto
en el mercado internacional no es algo
que suene muy marxista leninista
precisamente verdad
además los secuestros y la extorsión
también pueden ser un negocio muy renta
y en eso las farc eran auténticos
maestros
[Música]
si a eso le sumas que don berna y su
oficina de envigado están protegidos por
un grupo de paramilitares anti
comunistas está claro que la guerra es
inevitable todo esto el municipio de
bojayá hoy inmerso en esta espesa
vegetación y maleza hallar al punto
norte y desde ahí la guerrilla de las
farc lanzaba los cilindros bomba hacia
allá hacia el otro extremo del municipio
los secuestros fue muy difícil así que
un día medina caracas uno de los
comandantes de las farc decide entrar
[Música]
el frente 16 de las farc por los
millonarios ingresos de la coca pasó de
ser un grupo de menos de 200 hombres a
una red con más de 800 guerrilleros que
suministraba gran parte de los ingresos
de la guerrilla es un hecho que las fal
tienen el control de la mayoría de zonas
donde se encuentran las plantaciones de
coca en colombia de hecho llevan varios
años extorsionando a los cultivadores
cocaleros sin embargo con medina caracas
al frente las farc llegaron a tener sus
propias plantaciones de coca y sus
propias redes
[Música]
estamos ya en el año 2000 y en estos
momentos el clan de cali ya está
totalmente desmantelado sin embargo la
cocaína sigue dando trabajo a miles de
colombianos por hacer un resumen tenemos
por un lado a la oficina de envigado con
don berna a la cabeza y las autodefensas
unidas de colombia protegiéndolo por
otro lado tenemos a las farc y por el
otro tenemos a un montón de bandas
criminales independientes a las que
vamos a llamar las máquinas
[Música]
por cierto esto que están escuchando es
la calle una canción compuesta e
interpretada por mí si les gusta pueden
encontrar
y justo en este escenario de atomización
del mercado de la cocaína colombia elige
a un nuevo presidente álvaro uribe uribe
había nacido en medellín y su principal
objetivo era acabar con la violencia que
había diezmado al país y así es como
comienza un periodo que podríamos llamar
max mafiosa álvaro uribe estaba
dispuesto a acabar con los guerrilleros
los paramilitares y los narcos a
cualquier coste por eso en el año 2005
el que era su ministro de defensa camilo
ospina bernal firmó la tristemente
famosa directiva 029 y por qué se hizo
tan tristemente famosa la directiva
decía literalmente que el gobierno daría
el equivalente a mil 900 dólares a
cualquier miembro de la fuerza pública
que llegaba bueno que asesinara a
cualquier miembro de la guerrilla o de
las fuerzas paramilitares todos en aquel
entonces era su militar colombiano y
querías ascender rápido en tu carrera o
ganar cierto dinero además lo único que
tenías que hacer es salir a la casa de
estos miembros de grupos armados
precarios de repente los muertos en las
farc y los otros grupos armados ilegales
se empezaron a contar por cierto pero
esperamos un momento porque esto sólo
fue el principio encontrar a miembros de
las farc no es tarea fácil sin embargo
la recompensa que daba el gobierno era
demasiado jugosa
[Música]
fue así como muchos militares asesinaron
a varios civiles inocentes después de
esto los vestían con el uniforme de las
farc y los armaban y con estas pruebas
con fotos iban a la oficina
correspondiente
[Música]
pero esto no pasó ni una ni dos veces
aquí en colombia contra los falsos
positivos se conducir una costumbre para
todo aquel que quería ganarse un dinero
de más 50
para que se hagan una idea al día de hoy
la fiscalía de la nación tiene más de
3000 casos de 'falsos positivos' fuertes
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque si es
verdad la política de uribe fue
extremadamente controvertida pero hay
algo que le tenemos que reconocer le
puso las cosas muy complicadas tanto a
las farc como a los narcos las redadas
tanto a los campos de coca como las
redes de distribución eran continuas así
que cuando tu enemigo común mata a los
tuyos a diario te alías hasta con el
mismísimo [__] si hace falta
[Música]
correos electrónicos pondrían en
evidencia nexos de las farc con el
narcotráfico las farc están presentes en
casi todas las horas
en algunos casos estas plantaciones
pertenecen a la oficina de envigado oa
otras
macri diferentes
otras plantaciones están directamente
gestionadas por la ejecutiva ni proceso
en la hoja de coca para que luego los
grandes cárteles se encarguen de su
distribución hacia otros
sin embargo a diferencia de los tiempos
de pablo escobar los carteles de
colombia han perdido el monopolio de la
distribución de cocaína por ejemplo
cuando quieren enviar su mercancía a
eeuu lo hacen a través de un cartel
mafioso mexicano que cogen la cocaína y
la transportan por vía terrestre
[Música]
y para los envíos a europa también
tienen sus conexiones con las mafias
italianas griegas o albano kosovares
pero de eso vamos a hablar en otro vídeo
lo más importante de todo es que aunque
aún existe el tráfico de cocaína me dice
una ciudad mucho más tranquila aún
existen barrios sobre todo en la
periferia donde es mejor no acercarse
porque puede ser un poco peligrosos pero
la verdad es que medellín ha cambiado
mucho
[Música]
esta pax mafiosa ha permitido que todos
los distintos actores envueltos en el
narcotráfico colombiano ya tengan muy
claras cuáles son sus zonas de actuación
y no interfieran con las de los demás y
os preguntaréis qué puede pasar ahora
que las farc están haciendo un acuerdo
de paz con el gobierno colombiano lo
cierto es que podría suponer una
oportunidad para todas esas bacrim que
podrían recuperar todas las áreas de
negocio que ahora están bajo control de
la guerrilla pero lo cierto es que ahora
todos estos carteles de narcotraficantes
también quieren negociar con el gobierno
un acuerdo de paz que sea tan provechoso
como el que están negociando las farc
las fans con su propia política e
incluso con su gente incluso tienen un
sitio web desde muchos años atrás
ellos se sientan a negociar con el
gobierno haciendo exigencias políticas
mientras que las baterías el gobierno
más posiblemente como grupos armados
legales delincuentes almas
así que ahora todos estos narcos se
preguntan por qué a ellos sí y a
nosotros no no olvidéis que los acuerdos
de paz entre el gobierno de colombia y
las farc son muy pero que muy
beneficiosos para los terroristas si
queréis entender mejor en qué consistió
este primer acuerdo de paz que se
sometió a referéndum en colombia y que
se parece mucho a lo que parece que
sería el segundo acuerdo de paz podéis
hacer clic en el vídeo de aquí
[Música]
pero ahora la pregunta es es posible
acabar con el tráfico de cocaína o cada
vez que se acaba con una banda aparece
otra que la sustituye podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros al
canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y tampoco
olvidéis visitar el canal de mi amigo
rick vallejo y canal encontrar
administraciones propias mis versiones
de clásicos del funk y el árabe entre
otros covers y por supuesto tutoriales
de cómo tocar guitarra y como siempre si
os ha gustado este vídeo darle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto soy pablo emilio escobar
gaviria haciendo equipo es fresco
[Música]